we've learned about the new depths of
Donald Trump's childish nature Attorney
General Jeff Sessions as you probably
know recused himself on the on all
russia-related matters before the
Justice Department when it became public
that he had lied about his contacts with
Russians during the Trump campaign and
was completely compromised on that issue
it was the correct decision for Jeff
Sessions to recuse himself at the time
Trump was just furious about it we know
Trump was furious because he said
publicly that if he had known Jeff
Sessions was going to recuse himself he
never would have chosen him as Attorney
General to begin with and what we have
now learned from a New York Times report
is that Trump was literally giving
sessions the silent treatment for two
days ignoring his calls to the point
that sessions actually had no choice but
to fly down to Donald Trump's mar-a-lago
Resort and before I get even into the
content of what they discussed
am I the only one who's annoyed that on
top of all the plights flights were
paying for with taxpayer money for
people Jeff Sessions had to fly to Mara
Lago simply because Trump wouldn't pick
up the phone on our dime that's a very
very disturbing thing to me but let's go
down now to the content of what they
discussed
supposedly when sessions flew down to
mar-a-lago they were going to be talking
about the travel ban
but when sessions got there Trump
instead of talking about the travel ban
wanted to talk about Jeff Sessions
Russia recusal and Trump immediately
started berating sessions for the
recusal saying he should reverse the
recusal which would have been completely
inappropriate and again it would have
been another example of the White House
it is an example of the White House
trying to exert power over the Justice
Department and Jeff Sessions straight-up
refused and this confrontation hadn't
been reported at all until yesterday's
New York Times article about it and it
reportedly is now part of Robert
Muller's investigation because yes it is
part of a possible obstruction of
justice case against Donald Trump
we know that Trump was looking at
forcing jeff Sessions to resign through
both public and private attacks against
him and now we know that Trump was also
privately pressuring Jeff Sessions to
undo that recusal and by the way there
are people online saying well listen
this this proves Jeff Sessions is an
honorable guy he did the right thing by
not undoing the recusal I guess undoing
the recusal would have been completely
untenable right it's not really about
Jeff Sessions morals or values he's a
lawyer and he realizes that it would be
boneheaded ly ignorant to undo a recusal
that was correctly made over something
so serious and sessions knew that it
would be bad for him to do that it would
put more attention on him it's the last
thing he would have wanted so those
praising sessions is this amazingly
moral and ethical guy for this give me a
break
as far as molars investigation we
learned yesterday that investigators
have been asking many of the people that
they've interviewed over the last few
months whether they believe that Trump's
pressure on sessions to Unruh cues
himself was part of an attempt to
obstruct the investigation and again
that tells us that Robert Muller is
looking directly at obstruction of
justice and as usual Rudy Giuliani
trying to run interference on this
entire State thing Rudy Giuliani saying
yesterday unruhe Cuse doesn't mean bury
the investigation it just means take
responsibility for it and handle it
correctly but don't be confused this is
a major major bombshell this is possible
criminal activity by the president very
strongly bolstering the obstruction of
justice case against Trump and it just
barely registers because of the
political environment that were in right
now considered the scope of the possible
obstruction case right now Trump fired
Preet Bharara because of his
investigations in New York he got rid of
the interim acting Attorney General
Sally Yates he fired FBI director James
Comey he got rid of Rod Rosenstein he
got rid of Andrew McCabe he pressured
Jeff Sessions to Unruh cues himself or
to resign so that he could put in a new
Attorney General to take control of the
investigation and now we're learning
that he may also be doing some pretty
sketchy stuff with Admiral Mike Rogers
and director of national intelligence
dan coats this is not what innocent
people do and I got an email from a
viewer saying sessions is a horrible
ideologue but he's not stupid and if he
isn't stupid the smartest thing that
Jeff Sessions could have done is
immediate
when here accuses himself sell out the
Trump team as soon as possible flip
cooperate with Robert Muller I don't
know if that's what Jeff Sessions did if
he did do that I hope that at some point
we learn about it
sessions does not strike me as one of
these ideologically loyal beyond all
reason types which Michael Cohen
supposedly is but might actually not be
as we'll soon find out
sessions actually does strike me as a
guy who looks out primarily for Jeff
Sessions and it would not be hugely
shocking to find out that immediately
after the recusal he got in touch with
Robert Muller and started working with
him we'll see
send me your thoughts you can discuss
this with us on our subreddit at david
pakman.com slash re d di t we will take
a quick break part two of my interview
with Douglas Layne is coming up next
today's episode of the program is made
possible in part by Cody which is an
innovative new cryptocurrency and online
payment platform that wants to
revolutionize how we send and receive
online payments cody stands for currency
of the internet and the goal is to build
an infrastructure for online payments
that simple transparent trustworthy
instantaneous as well as scalable and
today's payment solutions have a number
of different trust and usability
problems whether it's between consumers
or between businesses or between
consumers and businesses and Cody wants
to solve a lot of those problems through
their currency and platform which unlike
a lot of the Kryptos and block chains
that are out there have actually been
created specifically and solely to be
used for payments cody has set out to do
this by using innovative base layer
protocol in the form of a directed
acyclic graph based ledger built from
transactions connected through time by
harnessing trust based algorithms if
you're watching this on youtube you can
find out more about cody and their
initial coin offering in the links below
this video this is not financial advice
and everybody should do their own
research